>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Robert J. Benz:
Well, welcome, everyone.
Thank you for being here.
This is an exciting day
for Frederick Douglass
Family Initiatives.
And my name is Robert Benz.
I am one of the Co-Founders
of Frederick Douglass Family
Initiatives, along with Ken Morris
and Nettie Washington Douglass.
And so here's how we're
going to do it today.
We have got some special guests,
some very important people
that you all will want to know
or at least see when they come up
and say a few words to us.
And then after they say a few words
we're going to have a conversation
with you all to talk
about our project and talk
about what abolition means.
And so the name of this project
is One Million Abolitionists.
Does anyone know what
an abolitionist is?
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Robert J. Benz: Someone who
is trying to abolish slavery,
that's one way of saying it.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Robert J. Benz: Advocating
for African-American rights.
Okay, we'll get deeply into this
in a few minutes, but the way --
there's going to be a big finish
to this and you all are going
to get the very first copies of
the brand-new Bicentennial Edition
of the Narrative of the Life of
Frederick Douglass and it's going
to be signed by the direct
descendants of Frederick Douglass
and Booker T. Washington.
Yes.
[ Applause ]
Okay, so before we get started we
have to acknowledge the friends
that we have here today, and
I've got a few to say hello to
and to say thank you to
before we get started.
First of all, our friend,
Kristen Leary [Assumed Spelling],
she is with our partner
organization,
the Frederick Douglass
Ireland Project.
Erica Cooper, thank you for being
here, she came in from Ohio,
she's an advisor of Frederick
Douglass Family Initiatives.
Reggie Wills [Assumed Spelling],
thank you, from Washington Latin,
thank you for bringing
the students with you.
Dionne Clark [Assumed Spelling],
thank you for the work you've done
with our organization
over the past few weeks.
Amy O'Neal Richard [Assumed
Spelling] from the State Department,
thank you for always being
supportive of our organization.
We're taking little steps, but
we're doing the best we can
to broaden those steps as we go.
Tara Morrison [Assumed Spelling],
did Tara come in from the
National Park Service?
No, but thank you, Tara.
Coleen Shogun [Assumed Spelling].
George Colburn [Assumed
Spelling], Library of Congress,
did I see -- George, thank you.
Duane Crawford from the
National Organization
of Black Law Enforcement Executives,
thank you for being here.
Max Scolnick [Assumed
Spelling], did I see Max come in?
My brother's keepers, I
may have heard -- yeah.
Kate Tyrell [Assumed Spelling] and
Ann Anderson [Assumed Spelling]
from the Embassy of Ireland, that's
a long drive, right, from Ireland,
that's someone dedicated.
Dr. Edwin Nichols [Assumed
Spelling],
did I see Dr. Nichols come in today?
I don't think I did, but thank you.
And I wanted to say
thank you to a few people
at the US Marshals Service.
Did any of the US Marshals
Service folks come in?
Yes, Dave Turks [Assumed
Spelling], thank you for being here.
Anyone know who was the first
African-American US Marshal?
Front row, front row?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes?
>> Frederick Douglass.
>> Robert J. Benz: Oh,
thank you, thank you.
[laughter]
[ Applause ]
I would give you a hint before
we get started that most
of the answers are
Frederick Douglass today, so.
[laughter] Well, I'm going to
give you all a special welcome,
or I'm not going to give
you a special welcome,
I'm going to have Pam Jackson,
who is with The Library
of Congress Center for the Book,
come in and say a few words to you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pam Jackson: Thank you, Robert.
So I don't have the pop quiz
questions, so I'm the safe speaker,
probably the last safe speaker
for you guys this morning,
this afternoon.
Thank you all for being here.
I am Pam Jackson, Director for
the Center for the Book and we're
in the National and
International Outreach Unit
of The Library of Congress.
And on behalf of Carla
Hayden, Librarian of Congress,
I welcome you here
with us this afternoon.
Thank you for being here.
So it's my job to just share
a little bit about the Library
and to remind some of us and
share newly with others of us
that it's the mission of
The Library of Congress
that we provide a rich enduring
diverse set of knowledge
and experiences designed to engage,
excite and stimulate the
intellectual and creative endeavors
of people everywhere and anywhere.
And we certainly know that Frederick
Douglass is a model for that for us.
So we're thrilled to be
in the conversation today,
very thrilled to be in
the conversation today.
And as part of being the
country's first cultural,
national cultural institution we
value this conversation even more
than that.
Also I should mention that
the Center for the Book has
as its mission the promotion of
libraries and literacy and books
and reading and poetry
and literature,
and we have that as our mission
because we believe deeply
in the power of words and ideas
and creativity to be shared,
to be relished, and to be used
as a power and a tool for good.
And now I'm speaking to the
first row when I say that,
that we care very much about
defending democracy and we know
that being literate matters more
than anything else in the power
and the capacity of people to
live in democratic societies
and be informed and engaged.
And that's what we're up to
at the Center for the Book,
that's why we're here today
in partnership with you
at the Frederick Douglass
Family Initiatives, and very,
very glad to welcome you.
Excited for what you're going
to be creating and knowing
that an abolitionist is a
special, special way of being
in today's society, with a
very special and critical role
that you can take on
and make your own.
So thank you for being here with us
in this conversation
to do just that.
Take care.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz: The place
where we're doing this today,
you guys know this is The Library
of Congress, is the biggest library
in the world, right,
this is where all
of the world's knowledge is stored.
So that woman that just spoke
is in control of almost all
of the knowledge of the world.
>> Pam Jackson: Almost.
>> Robert J. Benz: And George
Culver [Assumed Spelling],
he's got the digital
connection to the world.
So that's how The Library
of Congress is about to,
they're about to get their digital
on and be everywhere and put
that knowledge everywhere.
Now, okay, so when I mentioned
the Frederick Douglass Family
Initiatives I said that,
I mentioned two names --
Frederick Douglass and
Booker T. Washington, right?
Now who knows how Frederick Douglass
and Booker T. Washington
were related?
Anyone? Hands, anyone?
Yes?
>> Father and son?
>> Robert J. Benz: No.
Anyone else?
Okay, I'm glad you didn't answer
because the answer is
they're not related.
That was a trick question.
However, they are connected
and they're connected
in a very special way, and they're
originally connected in one person
and I'm about to introduce that
one person to you right now.
She is the Chair of the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiatives
and her name is Nettie
Washington Douglass.
Say hello to Nettie.
[ Applause ]
>> Nettie Washington Douglass:
Oh, my, good afternoon, everyone.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Nettie Washington Douglass:
And I have to say Frederick
Douglass still fills a room.
[laughter] Thank you
so much for coming.
How many of you thought you were
going to see him here today?
[laughter] I am delighted.
Thank you so very, very
much for joining us.
This is a very special
project and I have my tissue
because I'm not sure I'm going
to be able to get through it
without shedding a tear or two.
I suppose I'm supposed to start off
by sharing with you how I happen
to be related to both Frederick
Douglass and Booker T. Washington,
and let me say it is truly, truly,
truly an honor, it's a privilege.
I don't know why it was me,
but I'm happy that it is.
My father, Frederick
Douglass the III,
was the great grandson
of Frederick Douglass.
Now you might assume that because
he's the III his father would have
been Frederick, Jr.,
but that's not the case.
My grandmother told me when
I asked her many years ago,
why did you name him the III?
And she said, well, the first one,
the Frederick Douglass had
passed away and Frederick,
Jr., so the III was next.
So that's why he's the III,
but his father is Joseph.
And my father was a surgeon.
He was commissioned, he graduated
from the Harry Medical
School [Assumed Spelling],
and he was commissioned to Tuskegee,
where the only black VA hospital
during World War II was located.
So he was on a dinner break and
often the doctors would choose
to go walk on campus and eat
dinner in the student dining hall
as opposed to the hospital
cafeteria.
So this night he's on his way to
have dinner, and it just so happened
that a young lady whose name
was Nettie Hancock Washington,
the granddaughter of
Booker T. Washington,
who was born in Tuskegee, grew up
in California, was home for a visit.
And she was literally rushing
across campus, a shortcut,
to go wherever she was going
to meet family or friends.
And, as Robert so eloquently
described it
when he wrote Huffington Post, the
collision between the two families,
and they were married
three months later
in Booker T. Washington's home.
And I am the product of that
union, and I'm an only child.
So I have the privilege of
joining the families together.
But I like to say that we
know that Frederick Douglass
and Booker T. Washington
were friends.
I grew up, I spent my summers in
Frederick Douglass' summer home
in Highland Beach,
and in the living room
of the cottage was always a picture
of Booker T. Washington he
had given Frederick Douglass
and he had signed his name on there.
And when Frederick Douglass passed
away, I like to say the baton
of leadership was passed
forward to Booker T. Washington.
But I recently found out, I think
it might have been the last time I
visited a Douglass home that we know
Frederick Douglass died February the
20th, 122 years ago, but I
didn't know until very recently
that the day before his
death he wrote a letter
to Booker T. Washington.
I would like to think, and I don't
know this to be a fact but I would
like to think it was the
last letter he ever wrote
and that it would have
gone to his friend,
Booker T. They had
discussed some things.
Frederick Douglass spoke at the
seventh commencement address
at Tuskegee, and I know they
were in communication about how
to expand the program at Tuskegee.
So Frederick Douglass
wrote a letter kind
of summarizing what they had
talked about and having no idea
that generations later they were
going to be in-laws, which I just --
that's a personal story I
just love sharing that story.
So that's how the two
families were joined.
I would like to, if I
may, just take a moment.
Whenever we do something we have
such support from our family
and it's not just the
Douglass side of the family.
I would like to thank the
Morris side for coming.
Kenny, Kenneth B. Morris,
Jr. I would like to thank
the Hancock side for coming.
That would be on my
maternal grandmother's side.
The Hancock's are being represented.
I thank you for joining us.
And then, of course,
the Douglass family.
We have Kevin and his family.
Kevin and I have the same
relationship to Frederick Douglass.
I thank you for coming.
And Terrence Bailey.
This is, I love showing this.
Terrence is our cousin.
He is truly a Bailey.
Well, we're all Bailey's,
but we know Frederick
Douglass changed his name,
but Terrence is related to
Frederick Douglass' brother, Perry,
and he lives on the
eastern shore of Maryland.
And I often talk about I'm an only
child, and Terrence has become
on the eastern side of
Maryland you've got 200 cousins.
[laughter] So I look forward.
Thank you, Terrence, for joining us.
And then Sheila, thank you.
She's from the Hancock side.
And I've been asked to give a
little story about the picture
that you're looking at, that's
on the front of the cover.
You know, it's a standard side pose
of his, but it's very, very special.
And, before I get into that, it
would not be here if it were not
for a very, very dear
friend of my mother's,
who invited me to come to something.
She had no idea it was a fundraiser,
and ultimately I was able
to locate the picture
that I couldn't find
after my grandmother died.
She'd put it on loan
to the Smithsonian.
And because of Marion
Jones [Assumed Spelling],
her daughter Christina is
here -- thank you for coming.
Christina wasn't feeling
well, but she came anyway.
I found it, and I found it in
the basement of the Smithsonian.
And it's a long story of
how it used to frighten me
when I was a child,
but now I love it.
He smiles at me and I am honored.
This picture, it looks like a
photograph, but it really is not.
My grandfather, Joseph, his
grandson, Joseph, drew it.
And unframed it's about
almost two-and-a-half feet
by three feet and that's unframed.
And it hung on my grandmother's
wall at her house
and it did, as a child, frighten me.
But when I recovered it from
the basement of the Smithsonian
and took it to Marlene Morris' house
and took the top off I swear he was
smiling, thank you for finding me.
And, last but not least,
with the family I have two
incredible daughter-in-laws.
One is Kenny's, I call her our
Anna of our family because she is
so supportive of the work that
Kenny is doing in traveling
around the country
as much as he does.
But I have another daughter-in-law,
who lives in Atlanta,
and unfortunately she
couldn't be with us today.
But her Auntie Mom and Uncle Pop,
right here with us, and I thank you
so much for coming, the Sherman's,
they live here and they're
so supportive of us, as well.
The last thing I would like to say,
and I know Robert is
probably going to,
but I'd like to thank Mike
Glenn for being so supportive.
He is just -- well, a couple of
weeks ago at the All Star game,
he was on the Board of the
National Basketball Retired Players
Association, but he was
elected as Vice Chairman.
And he is a collector of rare books.
He has an incredible
collection of memorabilia.
He has something on
exhibit in Atlanta now.
And before I even met
him he had written a book
about Frederick Douglass.
And so I went to him last
summer when this concept came
up about what we wanted to do, and
he immediately saw the importance
of what we were trying to do
and he took it to his Board.
I want to thank him because the NBA
Retired Players Association was our
first sponsor where they
actually gave money for books.
So, Mike, thank you very, very
much for helping us get started.
So, with that, I think I am through.
I thank you again so very much
from the bottom of my heart
that you would take time out today.
I know some of you probably
are taking breaks from lunch
or whatever, but it means so much
to us to see the support here.
And, again, from the bottom
of my heart I thank you
for being a part of this.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz:
Nettie keeps saying
in meetings this week how
eloquently I wrote about her,
but I don't recall
specifically about that.
But if anyone is taking notes
it was in a blog I believe
in 2011 honoring Women's
History Month.
Is it Women's History
Month or Women's Month?
>> Women's History.
>> Robert J. Benz:
Women's History Month, yes,
I should have remembered that.
Yes, it's called Women for Women
and it describes in more detail
that collision at Tuskegee
between Nettie's father and mother.
Nettie, you took my -- thank you.
So we're talking about the One
Million Abolitionists project,
right?
>> Right.
>> Robert J. Benz: Okay, so again
when we say the word, abolitionist,
most of us think about the
idea of ending slavery.
How many know that there is
still slavery in the world today?
I know that, too, and it's true.
And the next person that
I'm going to introduce you
to is the most important person
on the issue of human trafficking
in the whole world today.
She works for the US
Department of State.
Anyone ever heard of that?
>> Yes.
>> Robert J. Benz: Yes, it's very
important, they deal with a lot
of affairs overseas and some
of them around here, too.
But this person is in charge of all.
In fact, her title has the
word, Ambassador, in it.
That means a lot, right?
Let me introduce to you from the
State Department, Susan Coppedge,
Ambassador at Large
in human trafficking
in the United States and abroad.
Susan?
[ Applause ]
>> Susan Coppedge: I
usually like the expectations
to be a little lower when
I'm going to stand up.
[laughter] But I do want to
thank you so much for asking me
to say a few words
today, and I'm so thrilled
at the front row that's here.
This One Million Abolitionists
project is very exciting,
and as a proud Georgian I'm happy to
be here with Douglass descendants,
Nettie Washington Douglass and
Kenneth Morris, so thank you.
You inspire us, inspire us all
to build upon Frederick
Douglass' extraordinary legacy
to combat modern slavery today.
My office has long engaged with
the Frederick Douglass Family
Initiatives and its
Co-Founders Ken and Robert
because we all value the
importance of the past
in informing what we're
doing today in the present.
We must understand
antebellum slavery
and inform what we're doing
today to combat modern slavery.
Human trafficking today affects
more than 20 million individuals
and these are men and women,
they're even children,
transgender individuals, who are
trapped, trapped and enslaved
in factories and on farms,
on fishing boats, in hotels
and on the streets across our
communities in the US and globally.
In the large conference room
in my office we have a
portrait of Frederick Douglass.
It's actually not as beautiful
as the portrait on the front
of the book, but it is our portrait
and we have it there as a reminder
of the power and courage
of an individual,
an individual who can motivate
my officers as they work
to fight trafficking around the
world, as they are motivated
and remember that an individual, one
person can make a difference even
under the most trying circumstances.
And before I was the Ambassador
I was a Prosecutor in Georgia,
and I actually think that was
a really important job, too,
especially for each trafficking
victim whose case I took
and whose trafficker I prosecuted.
And it's important to pursue
this through law enforcement.
A police officer can
make a difference.
He can see a trafficking victim as
a victim of crime and not someone
who has committed a crime.
It can also be the citizen who
turns in something suspicious.
It can be the person who talks
to their friends at school
about what modern day slavery is.
All of these individuals
can make a difference.
Prevention is also an
important part of this program
so that there isn't
victimization in the first place.
And, again, here the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiatives is very
important because they have
been educating and working
through awareness building
in schools
and now advocacy in this book.
This will continue
to spread the message
of what historical
slavery looks like
and what modern day
slavery looks like.
Frederick Douglass, himself,
was born on the eastern shore,
not very far from where we are
today, and he believed strongly
in the power of knowledge.
He said, knowledge makes
a man unfit to be a slave.
And it is so fitting that his
descendants are here and they want
to use knowledge to educate this
generation, but also those of us
in the room who need
a refresher course.
To read this book and to figure out
how you're going to use your talents
to fight causes that
you feel strongly about,
modern slavery being one of them.
Discover your gifts and how they can
be used to help in this great cause.
The State Department's
Anti-Trafficking Office welcomes you
in this fight and we know
that you have it in you.
Read this book and discuss it
with your peers, your parents,
anyone you can find and talk
about what you are going
to do to make a difference.
We look forward to seeing how this
generation tackles the incredible
problem of slavery through the
example of Frederick Douglass.
Thank you so much for having
me here today and good luck.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz:
Thank you, Ambassador.
You know, if the photo in the office
is not good enough I'm guessing
that for a small six-figure grant
we could license this photo to you.
[laughter] I may be
going out on a -- okay.
So now let's talk about people
who are already excited
about the project.
I want to introduce you to
this gentleman, who is a friend
of our organization,
has been a friend
of our organization for awhile.
The most amazing I think about
this friend of ours is that he went
through elementary school,
secondary school and high school
without ever missing
a day, how about that?
And he was also drafted in the
first round of the NBA draft.
We've got a couple of former
NBA players in the house today,
but this one is the Vice Chair
of the National Basketball
Retired Players Association,
Mike Stinger Glenn.
Mike?
[ Applause ]
I can't stop talking about
that, not missing a day.
[laughter]
>> Mike Glenn: Thank you very much.
First of all, let me
say I'm very excited
to be here, very honored to be here.
Thank you all for inviting
me and, Nettie,
thanks for all those wonderful
things that you said about me.
And I just want to let everybody
know that as the Vice Chairman
of the National Basketball Retired
Players Association we are honored
to be a partner with this initiative
and sharing this information
and knowledge with everybody
throughout the country
and the world.
So when I took it to
our Board and told them
of the proposal everybody
had questions about it,
they knew of the book,
and our Board took a vote
and it was a unanimous decision that
we should support and I should go
to the book launch and
anything else I could do
to help further the cause.
So the NBA Retired Players
Association very much is in favor
of everything that the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiatives
is doing.
And personally I'd just like
to say just a little bit,
both my parents were teachers, so
usually when I tell young people
that they kind of feel sorry for me.
They go, oh, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, you know?
[laughter] So I tell them you know
what you were going to do a lot
of if both your parents were
teachers, a lot of what?
>> Reading.
>> Mike Glenn: Reading
and studying, yes.
And one of the earliest motivating
factors my mom would always use
when we had these study periods,
we studied throughout the year
and we even had them in the
summertime, and she'd say now, Mike,
you can read a book, a newspaper
or magazine of your choice,
but at the end of it I want
to know what lesson did you
learn from what you read?
So when we read something we
couldn't just read something,
we had to answer to Mom, well,
what lesson did you learn, Mike?
So I grew up having to put into
words what lessons I had learned.
And she gave me an example early
of who her hero was and this stayed
with me throughout my life, many,
many years before I had a
chance to meet Ms. Douglass.
She told about the story
of Frederick Douglass
and she would kind of dramatize
it and when he was young
and he had learned
that once you learn how
to read it would forever
unfit you to be a slave.
And she made me memorize that
and say you always remember that,
how important it is for you to
read books and gain knowledge,
and how it will impact your life.
So she would keep articles,
when they had a stamp that came
out of Frederick Douglass
she kept it, and I still have
that newspaper today and that
was just so many years ago.
And I was just so proud to meet all
of the Frederick Douglass relatives,
family, descendants and to
participate in this initiative
because I know how important
it has been in my life.
And also as a collector, also I'd
like you to know I'm a collector,
I collect rare books, first edition
books, I have thousands of books.
But my most valued book in my
entire collection is that book
that was published in 1845,
published in the Anti-Slavery Office
of Boston, Narrative of the
Life of Frederick Douglass.
And then when she told
me they were going
to reissue it I just thought
it was the greatest thing ever.
I think it's the best book.
It got many reviews as being
one of the best books written
on an American press at that time.
And in its time period it outsold
Moby Dick, The Scarlet Letter,
and Leaves of Grass and
many of its contemporaries.
So it's a phenomenal book and
I think we all should read it
and reread it till it's not
only history, but philosophy,
faith, prophetic in many ways.
So I'm just glad to
be affiliated with it,
and on behalf of the retired NBA
players, our Board and our members,
even our current members,
because they're all going to know
about Nettie, current players
will, too, because we're going
to make sure to bridge that gap
between retired players
and current players.
And I'm sure they would agree with
me in that we are proud to be a part
of this and we are thankful,
and we salute all of you
who are here with the same feelings.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz: As a collector of
signed first editions Mike whispered
to me earlier that this signed first
edition is now priced at $5,000
and who knows what it's
going to be tomorrow.
[laughter] Actually, we
can give you the price.
Just before we go to our next guest,
the idea that we had
sometime last year as we began
to develop this project is
that we would give this away
to one million young
people with the idea,
just as Ambassador Coppedge
said and as Mike just said,
knowledge makes a man unfit.
It is not an idea that was only
relevant in 1845 or at any time
when Frederick Douglass was alive,
it's an idea that is alive today.
And knowledge, education,
reading, understanding is
so important not just to young
people, but just to everyone
to preserve the freedom that we
believe that we were all born
with the right, our birthright.
So we are -- we don't have the, I
hate to say we don't have the money
to print a million copies,
in case anyone thought
by looking at us we did.
[laughter] So we are
going to endeavor to go
out over the next few months
and raise about $4 per book.
It's a beautiful hardcover copy book
and hopefully we'll get some
sponsors along the way and people
who are enthusiastic
enough about the project
to help us raise $4 per
book in their communities
so that we can come out, present
the book and create conversations
in communities that are meaningful,
not only to the young people
but to the neighbors and
everyone else who lives
and breathes in those communities.
Ken and I are starting in Chicago,
in Atlanta, and we'll be in Flint,
Michigan as well in a few weeks
where, in case you missed the news,
the Flint water crisis was created
in part because of systemic racism.
And this is what we want
to talk about and address
through discussions about this book.
Okay, next.
So, you know what, did I see --
did Vince, Vince, did you come in?
Oh, now this would be a favorite of
yours, not that the others weren't.
But we were in a meeting with
our new partner on this project,
the National Park Service, and this
guy is so energetic that I felt
like I had to sleep as soon as --
after he got done talking I felt
like, God, I've got to take a nap.
Say hello to Ranger Vince from the
Frederick Douglass Historic Site,
Cedar Hill Home.
Are you from Cedar Hill, Vince,
or just National Park Service?
>> Vince Vaise: Both.
>> Robert J. Benz: Both.
Come on up and say hi to everybody.
[ Applause ]
>> Vince Vaise: Just like to say
we are living through a golden age
in the National Park Service
for African-American history.
Two days ago we turned the
lock that opened the door
to the Carter G. Woodson
Home National Historic Site.
[ Applause ]
Which as we all know without
Woodson we would not have Black
History Month.
A lot of us know that.
How many of us in this room know
that one of the other great things
that Woodson did was to go through
and organize Frederick
Douglass' papers?
He did that, and I think that
shows the interconnectedness
of this history.
And then as we're talking
about getting ready
for the Bicentennial I think we have
to ask what is the
purpose of a Bicentennial?
Can we say that Frederick
Douglass is any less important
in this 199th year of his
birth versus next year,
as he will be in the 200th year?
>> No.
>> Vince Vaise: Or perhaps maybe
we all just like round numbers,
maybe that's what makes 200th
so neat, the 100th anniversary
or the 200th, maybe it's
a round numbers thing.
But you know what Bicentennials do?
They wake us up from our historical
amnesia because as time goes
by we forget things,
we forget people.
And when we have a Bicentennial
it is that round number
that we can hang our hat
on that wakes people up.
We have the choir in
the audience today,
but what the National Park
Service is doing in partnership
with the Frederick Douglass Family
Initiative is to carry that legacy
to a new generation of
Americans, a new generation
of young people, and
to make it relevant.
Right now in the National
Park Service one
of the initiatives is called the
Urban Agenda, and the idea is
that National Parks can be
catalysts for civic change.
Whether that is a nature park that
could raise the living standards
in a blighted neighborhood, a
place where people can recreate,
or a historical park, like
Frederick Douglass' Cedar Hill
where people can take pride
in the most prominent
resident of Anacostia.
These places are inspirational
and, again,
they can inspire that
next generation.
So what are we going
to do about that?
Well, in partnering with the
Frederick Douglass Family Initiative
we're developing a new educational
package, an educational package
that will be actually
in the National Park Service
go to students nationwide.
Yes, we want students to visit
Cedar Hill and we plan to have
between 7,000 and 10,000 of
them visit Cedar Hill in 2018,
targeting at least 200 additional
school groups, one for each year
of the Bicentennial you understand.
[laughter] It works, you know?
But also target students to visit
Cedar Hill that lived in areas
where Frederick Douglass lived
and grew up, places such as
on the eastern shore of
Maryland, places such as New York,
places such as not only
here in Washington, D.C.,
Baltimore City, places like that.
And then through the distance
learning, using media,
the widespread media where
students around the world can engage
and they'll be able
to talk to Kenneth --
can I call you Kenneth Morris --
Kenneth Morris, they can talk,
you know, a descendent, I
mean how cool is that to
where kids can be like, yeah, you
know what, when I was a kid I talked
to this descendent of Frederick
Douglass, I remember that,
and I went to Cedar
Hill with my class,
and I still have that
book on the shelf.
But, ladies and gentlemen, the power
of history is not just in a bunch
of facts and dates
and names of the past.
If that's what it was, and
when you talk to people
and they say I've never
liked history,
that's the way it was
taught to them.
You know, because you're laughing
it probably happened to yourself.
But the power of history, because if
that's all it is is memorizing facts
then this is just a grand
game of trivial pursuit.
Can you recall this?
But the power of history
is the ability of the past
to influence the present
and to influence the future,
and by grooming that next generation
of stewards, to show the relevance
of what Frederick Douglass
did back then
to what the National Park
Service is doing today,
to combine that Frederick Douglass
history with the modern blight
of human trafficking and
have students understand
that this stuff is still going
on and that they will be inspired
to take action is a new relevancy,
it will jumpstart that cause.
We have a lot of special exhibits
that our Curatorial Division
will be putting out this year,
so we're excited to actually
engage in the artifacts
that Frederick Douglass touched
and used, but also again to inspire
that next generation through
education and through civic action.
And maybe 50 years from now, how
many of us will be in this room,
probably not a lot, but those kids
that we will be inspiring this year
and 2018 they will be in this room,
they will be carrying that torch on.
And we will that, so remember the
power of history is the ability
to influence the present
and to influence the future,
and it's that power that we
will be harnessing in 2018.
Mr. Benz, it's an honor
to work with you,
the journey has just begin, sir.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz: I'm officially
shamed about my lack of enthusiasm.
[laughter] But that
was a day at church.
I could have gone for
another half hour of that.
But I wonder who is next?
[laughter] No, I know who is next.
Listen, this is an important
conversation that we want
to put ourselves in the middle of.
We've been having these
conversations
over the last few years
in our communities
about perceived differences
between us.
One thing we want you all to learn
when you're reading this book is
that there are no differences
between us,
there are perceived
differences between us.
And the only way that we
can overcome those people
that are trying to make us believe
that there are differences is
to unite, is to become one.
And that's what you guys
have to do, that's your jobs.
We'll try, too, we'll do a
little bit of it ourselves.
But to show that unity, we are
so proud to have with us as part
of this project the
National Organization
of Black Law Enforcement Executives,
and I would like to ask Chief
Perry Tarrant to come up
and say a few words, please?
[ Applause ]
>> Perry Tarrant: Well, I'm going
to start by saying good afternoon.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Perry Tarrant: I wasn't
expecting to find Mr. Douglass here,
but I thought his best friend
who lives down the street
on Pennsylvania Avenue
would be here, so.
But having said that, again,
my name is Perry Tarrant.
I'm the President of the
National Organization
of Black Law Enforcement
Executives, or NOBLE for short.
My Executive Director, who is here
locally in the D.C. area is here,
Duane Crawford [Assumed
Spelling], he's in the back.
And I also want to acknowledge
Andrea Dawson [Assumed Spelling],
who is a member of our organization
who is out of Los Angeles
who connected me to this
organization or to the initiative.
So you're trying to figure out
what does the National Organization
of Black Law Enforcement
Executives have to do
with the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiatives?
I'll start off by giving
you a history lesson.
So there's two histories
of policing.
The first history of policing
is the Police Service,
which started in Europe and it
was founded by Sir Robert Peale
and the concept there was
the people are the police
and the police are the people.
You have the history of policing in
the United States, which started off
as the police or slavecatchers,
they hunted down runaway slaves
and returned them as property.
I'm not suggesting to you
that we can't bridge the two
and bring the two together because
that's what my organization does.
I spend a lot of time in cities
like Ferguson, Missouri, Charlotte,
North Carolina, and a
variety of other cities
where we've had a number
of recent events.
And the goal of our
organization is exactly in line
with being an abolitionist.
So the intent here with our
organization really is justice
by action, and that's our motto.
Where the two organizations align
and connect is our organization
absolutely enforces constitutional
law, not amongst the
community but amongst my peers.
I'm the guy who calls those
police chiefs and those sheriffs
and ask them the hard question.
I'm the guy who gets to call
those police chiefs and sheriffs
and say we're coming to your
town to find out what happened.
That's what my organization does.
We're about 3,000 strong.
We've got chapters all over the
United States, as well as Canada,
the UK, and the Caribbean.
We leverage all of those
chapters because of our depth
to have those conversations.
One of our initiatives is a program
we call The Law in Your Community.
Every one of our chapters across
the country has a representative
or has access to that program,
and what that program does is it's
tailored for youth between the ages
of 14 to 25 and it's a conversation
about what your constitutional
rights are.
A lot of folks out there believe
or think they know what their
constitutional rights are,
but we have that conversation
and tell you very specifically
in that contact with law
enforcement what your rights are,
what to expect, if it does not
go well what your redress is.
And I would suggest to you that
three o'clock in the morning
on the side of the road is not the
time to fight for your rights, okay?
The conversation is comply unless
there is an absolute threat
to our life at that moment and
then follow-up afterwards using the
process that we described,
which varies from state to state
and organization to organization.
In the United States there are about
18,000 different police departments,
which means there's 18,000 different
ways of things happening out there.
There's about 800,000
police officers from local
to Federal across the country.
The value of our organization
and other organizations
that are very similar and align to
us is to ensure that your rights
as an individual are protected.
And, again, we're not
looking at the community,
we're looking at our
peers and making sure
that the equitable administration
of justice, the 14th Amendment,
is enforced coast to
coast for every citizen,
for every person living
in the United States.
And if you read the 14th
Amendment it doesn't say citizen,
it says every person.
I began my law enforcement
career in the State of Arizona,
which was the first state to
have its own immigration law.
I'm currently a Chief
in Seattle, Washington.
The organization that I represent
is predominantly made up of chiefs
and sheriffs and, or command level
personnel again from coast to coast.
This is a natural partnership for
us, this is a natural conversation
for us to have with the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiative.
It's a natural conversation
because we want the same thing
and that is we want to make
sure that everybody who is
in the United States has
justice equally applied to them.
Thank you for the invitation
to speak before you.
Thank you for being here.
And we are absolutely partners.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz: That, what you
just heard was very important stuff
and I want to congratulate
us for putting together
such an interesting program today.
[laughter] The next person I want to
introduce you to provides the link
between NOBLE and Frederick
Douglass -- what do we call it --
Frederick Douglass
Family Initiatives.
And I'm going to raise this a little
bit for Mr. Dawson, a tall man.
I want to introduce
you to the gentleman
who has been extremely
valuable to our organization.
He's one of the top minds in
the anti-trafficking world today
and he does training for law
enforcement officials all
over the United States and
he provides sage wisdom
for Frederick Douglass Family
Initiatives, and he's spent a lot
of time trying to figure out
how to approach this issue
of human trafficking in the United
States and I think he's probably got
as good a take as anyone
in the United States.
Say hello to Lieutenant
Andre Dawson.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Andre Dawson: Hello
and good afternoon.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Andre Dawson: It's an absolute
honor and pleasure to be here.
I've never had the chance
or the opportunity really
to tell the Frederick Douglass
Family Initiatives how proud I am
to work with them and today will
be the day for me to say that.
I'm so honored and privileged to
be a part of this organization,
and I would like certainly to
make sure I do the best I can
to advance this agenda
as best as I can.
So thank you so much.
[child cries] And that, too.
I have to share a personal story
with you, when I got onboard
with the Frederick Douglass Family
Initiatives I heard a lot of stories
about this spiritual connection
between the Frederick Douglass
Family, people within the community,
that there's this connection.
And I've heard multiple
stories of it,
as a matter of fact I met Ken's mom
for the first time during this trip
and we were sitting
down and having dinner
and she was sharing these spiritual
connection stories with me.
And I'm going to share one with
you and I'm also sharing this
with our young people here.
We went to the African-American
Museum on Saturday,
and it was raining a little bit.
And Ken wanted to go visit the
medallions of Frederick Douglass
and Booker T. Washington.
And it was raining a little bit.
And one of the pictures that Ken
wanted to take was him kneeling
down with the picture, I mean with
the book of Frederick Douglass.
And we were trying to wait for
the weather, the rain to stop
so that Ken can do this,
but when we stood there,
there was a lady standing there.
And Ken is to her right and she's
literally in between the two of us,
and I'm looking at this
lady and we're trying
to let her finish doing whatever
it was that she was doing.
And she stood there for several
minutes, I mean to the point
where at some point when she
finished I literally asked her was
she okay?
And what she said was, you know,
she was looking at the words
and those words meant something
to her, and to the point
of this spiritual connection.
I really wasn't sure if she
was ready for me to tell her
who was standing to her right
after what she was going
through, but I did.
I said to your right, and I was
ready to, in case she collapsed
or something, I was -- to your
right is a direct descendent
of Frederick Douglass.
And she embraced Ken and what
she said was she didn't know much
about Frederick Douglass,
but to my point,
to my youth here, words do matter.
Appreciate the book that
you were given today.
Embrace the history of
a great man and learn
about the sacrifices
that shaped the world.
It will make a difference
to you, okay?
The words that I'm going to
share with you, some of them,
if you get a chance there's an
amazing introduction written
to this book by Brian
Stevenson [Assumed Spelling].
And I'm going to share the
quote from Frederick Douglass,
who once said, it is easier
to build strong children
than to repair broken men.
Today is the beginning
of one million students making their
own journey of hope and success.
Today is a new beginning for you,
and I'm glad to be here
to be a part of that.
But we as responsible adults
we have to demonstrate a moral
and social obligation to be
proactive and travel this journey
with Frederick Douglass and help
build these strong children.
Today we introduce the
words of Frederick Douglass
that will show us all the way.
Law enforcement, we won't
arrest our way out of this,
but we will walk this
journey with you,
as the Chief just shared with you.
I've seen what it looks like,
a 14 year old to be exploited.
Six of my 33 years I've spent
specializing in the rescue
and recovery of children who
have been sexually exploited.
Close to my retirement
and what kept me going was
after I rescued three
law enforcement daughters
and a high profile
athlete's daughter.
It can happen to anyone anywhere.
So what I told my Chief was,
I have to figure out how
to help in some kind of way.
Because I sit in a very unique seat,
for those last six years I worked
for the FBI and the Los
Angeles Police Department
and not very many people
have done that.
But I traveled the world and when I
did I was able to sit down and talk
to people and tried to identify
what the best practices were
in bringing those back
to Los Angeles.
But today [child cries] -- yes?
[laughter] Today the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiative is making
a fight for human rights and deposit
into the lives of these children.
[child cries] And you, too.
In closing I will share this, if we
as a country are going to subscribe
to making America great let's begin
by supporting the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiatives
and let's work together to
educate one million children.
A protected child is
an educated child,
and all of our children are God's
children and they are all great.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz: There's a man
who looks like he could protect you
and he's also got a gigantic heart.
We love Lieutenant Andre Dawson.
Okay, so just, you know,
Andre referenced the book,
we are going to, after we have
a little discussion we're going
to hand out these copies of
the book to the students.
We have a couple more.
We do accept bribes.
The book is for the students and,
you know, people have called us
and said, how do I get a book?
And, frankly, we don't,
we're not book publishers,
we don't know necessarily
how to retail the book
and we didn't create it for that.
If you have a desire to have a
book in your hands and have one
of your own there are a couple
of ways of going about it.
Again, we wouldn't reject checks
and cash, but what we would really
like you to do is to make
up your minds to go back
to your communities, think
about who might be able to help
in your community, is it the local
PTA, the local car dealership,
the local bank, who is it that
could invest a few dollars
to help your community
bring a thousand books to it
or to bring 5,000 books
to our community.
And if you do we will come with
the books as an added accessory.
[laughter] So and we'll hand you one
in person, that becomes your own.
So that's the story about the books.
We really want, and
again we're flexible,
but what we really want is
a million books in the hands
of a million young people
who can go out and begin
to create change in our communities.
So now I'm going to introduce
to you my partner in the project
and a partner in the Frederick
Douglass Family Initiatives who Ken
and I have been at
this now for 10 years.
I just realized it was 10 years
because LinkedIn told me, basically.
[laughter] Congratulations,
it's your 10-year anniversary.
I was waiting for someone
to tell me that,
I just didn't think it
would be a computer.
Say hello to the great, great,
great grandson of Frederick Douglass
and the great, great grandson
of Booker T. Washington,
Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.
[ Applause ]
>> Kenneth B. Morris,
Jr.: Thank you, Robert.
This is an emotional
day for the family,
for my mom, talked about it earlier.
And to see all of you
here supporting this work
and supporting the young people
that are in the front row.
On behalf of the Family
of Frederick Douglass
and Booker T. Washington we
thank you for being here.
We're very humbled that you're
here and we're just excited
to have a conversation with the
students about this project.
But before we jump into that I
just wanted to say a few words
about what it's like to be a
descendent of Frederick Douglass
and Booker T. Washington.
Wow. And as Robert introduced me I
think I heard him say I'm the great,
great, great grandson
of Frederick Douglass,
is that right, were
there three greats?
Yes, and the great, great
grandson of Booker T. Washington.
And every time I tell people
what my relationship is
to these American heroes not only
is it a mouthful trying to spit
out all those greats,
but it sometimes makes
me feel very far removed.
And you might be sitting there
having a hard time trying
to imagine what my connection
is to Douglass and Washington.
It's like trying to picture
what a billion dollars looks
like with all those zeroes or in
the case of the project $4 million
with all of those zeroes.
But I'd like to talk about my
great grandmother, Fannie Douglass,
who lived to be 103 years old.
And she met Frederick Douglass
when she was a little girl.
She didn't know that she was going
to grow up and marry his grandson,
who by the way is the artist
on the cover of the book,
but that's what happened.
And my Aunt Portia, to whom I was
also very close, she lived to be 95
and she was Booker T.
Washington's daughter.
And I remember being a
little boy and sitting
on my great grandmother
Fannie Douglass' lap
and she would tell me what it was
like to know, as she would call him,
the man with the great
big white hair.
And I remember sitting
on my Aunt Portia's lap
and she would tell me firsthand
stories about her father.
And when I was thinking about the
generations and how far it seems
like I'm removed because
some were looking
at me like, wow, that's so far away.
And one evening when I was
thinking about that it hit me,
hands that touched the great
Frederick Douglass and hands
that touched the great Booker
T. Washington also touched mine.
So in a sense to be with
all of those greats I stand
as just one person in
the wave of history.
I stand one person
away from slavery.
Now Rob and I had the
opportunity over the past 10 years
that we've been doing this work
to dialogue with tens of thousands
of students, and I think sometimes
most of the kids that we come
in contact with think that
slavery happened so long ago.
And when you look at
great heroes and heroines
in the history books it's hard to
imagine that they were living people
that did so much, they overcame
obstacles and challenges.
In the case of my ancestors and many
others they rose up to affect change
in the lives of millions of people.
So what I want to do this afternoon
with you guys is make history
come alive because I want to talk
about two men that
were born into slavery.
They were born in the
most horrific conditions
that a human being
could be subjected to,
but yet with the power of education.
Now Frederick Douglass never spent
one day of his life in a classroom.
Can anybody tell me why he
wouldn't have had a chance
to get an education?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Kenneth B. Morris,
Jr.: That's one reason,
there were no black schools, but
I'm looking for something else.
Any ideas of why as an enslaved
person Frederick Douglass couldn't
spend any time in a classroom?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.: Well, not
a lot of people could read or write,
but why do you think it was
that people that were enslaved,
held in bondage couldn't
read or write?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Kenneth B. Morris,
Jr.: No one taught them,
we're getting a little bit closer.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.:
Well, they were working,
they were enslaved, they
didn't have their own humanity,
they didn't own themselves.
The reason that -- what I'm
looking for is that it was illegal
to teach the slaves
to read and write.
So not only did the Federal
Government want to keep those
who were enslaved in
physical bondage,
but most importantly they wanted
to keep them in mental bondage.
And this is a message that's
relevant today, and as you hear
about this project as we move
forward what we want to do
when we pass out a million
books between now and the end
of the Bicentennial year in 2018 is
we want young people to be inspired
by Frederick Douglass's
words and his examples
of courage and taking action.
And why has he not become one of
this country's greatest heroes?
Frederick Douglass was
born Frederick Augustus
Washington Bailey.
He was born on the eastern shore
of Maryland to a black woman
who was enslaved and to a
white man and it is presumed
that his father was his master.
He never had a pair
of pants or shoes
until he was about eight years old.
He used to sleep head first in an
old corn sack on cold winter nights
with his feet hanging out because
that's the only way he could try
and keep himself warm.
He only saw his mother about four
times his whole life and that's
because he had been
separated from her.
It was not unusual for the
master to separate the children
from their mothers
when they were born.
So his mother lived on a
plantation that was 12 miles away.
So in order for her to see her
son she would have to pick cotton
in the fields from sun up to sun
down, walk 12 miles in the middle
of the night to spend just a
few precious moments with him
until he would fall asleep, and then
she would have to walk 12 miles back
so she could be back on the
plantation by the time the sun came
up because if she wasn't she
was most likely going to have
to face a brutal beating.
So he was raised by his
grandmother in the early years,
and his grandmother's
job on the plantation was
to raise the slave children
until when they were old enough
to begin their life in manual labor.
And on this plantation that was
usually right around six years old.
Now Frederick didn't know old he was
because there were no birth
certificates for slaves.
He was taught someone else owned
him, he did not own himself.
So his grandmother said to him
when he was around six years old,
we're going to go on a long journey.
And that journey was a 20-mile
walk to the main plantation
where she would drop him off because
she had done this many times before
with the other children
she had raised.
Because now he was at the age
where he could begin his work,
where he enters really what
he called the el slavery.
So they made that walk, they made
the last final walk and he arrives
and he kind of runs
out to see where he is.
And when he turns around to look
for his grandmother she's gone.
So here is a boy, he didn't know who
his father was, he'd been separated
from his brothers and sisters, he
only saw his mother four times,
and any person that
showed him any nurturing
and love is out of his life.
So he's truly alone.
So what we have is a little
boy who has no family,
he has no home and
he has no country.
And in spite of all that he had
something happen in his life
that he called divine providence.
Now I have to think that history
is important for a lot of reasons,
but I think history is most
important because we need to know
where we come from in order
to know where we're headed.
And right now do you guys realize
we're making history right now,
with the launch of this project,
and what's going to come afterwards.
And you all are the first
students that are going
to be getting these books.
And so what's going to happen
is all the other students
around the country and young people
that we want to connect to are going
to be looking at you for examples.
So it doesn't seem like it
but making history right now,
and I'm about to tell you a
story that I want you to listen
to because had this not
happened the course of history
in our country may have taken a
different turn or a different path.
And that was that Frederick
was chosen
from among all the slave
children on the plantation to go
to the eastern shore of
Maryland where he was born,
Frederick Augustus
Washington Bailey,
to Baltimore to be the house
servant for his master's brother.
Now when he got there his slave
mistress had never had slaves before
and she didn't know
that it was illegal
to teach him to read and write.
Listen to this, so she begins to
teach young Frederick his ABC's,
but when her husband finds out about
it, when Frederick's master found
out he got mad and he forbade it.
And he looked at his wife, Sophia,
and he looked at little Frederick
and said, you heard today, you
cannot teach a slave how to read
and write because if you do it
will unfit him to be a slave.
So Frederick quoted his master,
he heard that message and he said,
if you don't want me
to have this I'm going
to do everything in
my power to gain it.
And he understood right then
that knowledge was power
and education would be
his pathway to freedom.
Knowledge is power, education
is your pathway to freedom,
that is a message that's
relevant today.
So he begins to teach
himself to read and write.
He was very clever in the
way that he would do that.
Now remember he's in the big city so
now he's around free black children
that didn't read and write, but
he's also around white children.
So he trades bread
for reading lessons.
He picks up something off the
ground and he scratches with a twig.
What's your name?
Ava. Can you tell me is
this how you write an A?
And you say, no, this
is how you write an A.
And he would file it away.
So now as he's starting to become
educated, so he started to look
around and he starts questioning
his conditions and asking questions
like why am I a slave
and why do you own me?
And so at the age of 20,
now you guys will learn
about all the details
in the narrative
if you haven't already read it
so I'm going to really skip ahead
in the interest of time, but at the
age of 20 he would disguise himself
as a sailor, carry with him
forged identification papers,
and he would escape slavery.
He would go by train and
boat to New York City
where he would marry my great,
great, great grandmother Anna,
and then along the Underground
Railroad they would make their way
up to New Bedford,
Massachusetts and he would settle
into New Bedford, Massachusetts.
Now here's a point that I'm going
to tell you about taking action
because this project
is about literacy,
but it's also about social
services, it's about taking action.
So he gets to New Bedford,
he could have said, well,
I'm in a free state now, yes, I'm
a fugitive slave, but he didn't.
He could have said I'm
going to start a family.
But he looked back and he saw that
there was this legal institution
of slavery that needed to be
dismantled and he got to work
to do that, along with
the other abolitionists,
so he would become an
advisor to President Lincoln
and a statesman and
an American hero.
So what we want to do with this
project, One Million Abolitionists,
is we want this book into the hands
of as many young people as possible.
And my mom can tell you this and
it's been my experience that ever
since I was a little boy, I remember
being four or five years old
and people would come up to me
sometimes with tears in their eyes,
they'd want to hug me, kiss
my cheeks, pat my hair.
And it was hard to understand
the emotional connection
that so many had to our ancestors,
but it was many years later somebody
came up to my mom at an event
and explained why people
react this way.
And they'd always remember
where they were
when they read the
Narrative, how old they were
or what grade they were in, so it
had that kind of impact on them.
And what this person said to my
mom is that Frederick Douglass
and Booker T. Washington meant
so much to me in my life,
that if I could thank them in
person I would, although some people
in the government think they
probably can thank him in person.
[laughter] But most of this know
that Frederick Douglass is not,
though his spirit is with
us, so he is still alive.
By thanking a person I would, but
because I can't you are the conduit
to that, so they want
to hug us and touch us.
And that changed my perspective on
this so I really embrace that now.
So history lives in each of us.
History doesn't just live in me
because I descend from somebody
that made a difference, but
lives in each and every one
of you and everybody here.
And for those of you that have
done your own family tree,
I'm sure you've found great heroes
and you're smiling, you did.
And we want young people everywhere
to think and to understand
and discover the same
thing, that we all descend
from people who made a difference.
And I remember there was a
young girl who was 10 years old,
she raised her hand and she said,
Mr. Morris, my great, great,
great grandmother was born into
slavery, she taught herself to read
and write and then she
freed or liberated herself
and she became a businesswoman
and a philanthropist.
And she looked at me and she
said, you know what that means?
She said, I have greatness flowing
through my veins just like you do.
And I said, yes, you do.
You have greatness flowing
through your veins, too.
And we heard the quote, it's
easier to build strong children
than to repair a broken man.
My favorite Frederick
Douglass quote.
My favorite Booker T. Washington
quote is, if you want to lift
up yourself lift up someone else.
And when you get into
the social service part
of this project you all are going
to be working in your communities
to lift up someone else, which will
lift up your community, your school,
and all the young people that
need hope, need inspiration,
and they need to connect
to these stories.
How many of you guys know that
Frederick Douglass is the father
of the Civil Rights Movement?
He's the one that started it all.
Well, there's a lot to be learned
and we're excited, and I just want
to give you a quick story about
the Narrative and then I'm going
to ask Robert to come up with
me and we're going to engage you
in a conversation with the
time that we have left.
A lot of work to do.
So Frederick Douglass settled
in New Bedford, Massachusetts.
He came into contact with
a white abolitionist,
William Lloyd Garrison.
And he attended an
antislavery meeting
in which Garrison was
speaking and he heard
that he had this fugitive slave in
the audience and he asked Douglass,
would you come up and would
you just tell me your story,
tell the audience what it
was like to be a slave?
And so he writes about this
later, he said I was so nervous
and I was shaking from every limb
and my knees were knocking together,
but he stood up and what he was
able to do, he had a natural gift
for communication, he was
eloquent, he was charismatic,
he was actual, he was funny.
But it was the first time
that the audience was hearing
from somebody really.
Now there had been other slave
narratives that had been written,
but it was the first time the
audience was hearing from somebody
that had experienced
slavery firsthand.
And that's why when we talk
about human trafficking,
modern day slavery today the voices
of survivor leaders are important
because you're hearing from people
that have suffered the injustice
and the inhumanity
and the brutality.
So the audience is looking at him
and they're thinking, wait a minute,
that's not what the slave
looks like or sounds like,
that's not what I've been told.
And so he is shattering this
notion and the public consciousness
about African-Americans
being worthy of citizenship,
being worthy to be
considered a human being.
So he would travel from town to town
with Garrison and tell the story,
people started to doubt that
he had ever been a slave
because they couldn't
wrap their minds
around what they were
hearing and seeing.
So in order to prove that
he wrote this Narrative,
which was published in 1845.
It became an instant bestseller.
Now we published 5,000 copies and
the significance of that number is
that was the original run of
Frederick Douglass' Narrative.
Now we understand that
he sold 4,000 copies.
Our 5,000 copies have already been
committed and will be delivered,
so maybe we've done a little bit
better than Frederick Douglass did.
But that's why he wrote
the Narrative
because in it he named names and he
named places, it became a bestseller
and made him a celebrity, it
made him a household name.
So he would have to flee to
Europe for a couple years
for a cooling off period,
and while he was
in Europe some abolitionist friends
of his pooled their money together
and purchased his freedom for
$711 and he was able to come back
to the United States
and become a free man
and to really begin his
work as a leading voice
in the abolitionists movement.
So that's the history
behind this Narrative.
And we know that it has
transformative properties to it
and we know that young people,
Robert and I have given away more
than 3,000 copies of another
edition in the past 10 years.
We've had students and
young people write us
and tell us how much this
book changed their lives.
So we know that it
will change your lives
and it will inspire
you to do great things.
So with that I'd like to ask Mr.
Benz to come up and we're going
to ask a few questions about
equality, injustice and other things
that are a concern in
our communities today.
>> Robert J. Benz: Well, before we
do that I want to remind everyone
that Frederick Douglass Family
Initiatives is a [inaudible] 501C3
if you want to make a donation
to Frederick Douglass Family
Initiatives to help us
with the project or if you
go home and inspire a spouse
or a family member, to do so.
We have ...
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.:
Envelopes on the back table.
>> Robert J. Benz: Envelopes
on the back table to do that.
In a moment we're also going to
give each of you your own copy
and then I'll have Nettie come
up also and shake your hands
as we give away a copy of the book.
Question for you guys,
so if you read the book
and you feel very inspired, now
you're going to do something
in your community to bring
awareness to something
that you feel strongly about.
Say it's human trafficking,
any ideas, what could you do,
projects that you could
do, any ideas?
Or you get together with your
classmates or your teacher?
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Robert J. Benz: Love that, so
you're educating your community
about what human trafficking
is, excellent.
Other ideas, anyone
else have another idea?
Yes?
>> You could do what she said,
except you could put them up instead
of walking around, to
like make a bunch of them,
you could like have a competition
and see who makes the best one
and then walk around
in your communities.
>> Robert J. Benz: Excellent,
sounds like kind of an ad campaign
where you have posters everywhere
to help people understand
what we're talking about.
Yes, other ideas, yes?
>> You could create a social media
account on a platform like Twitter
and you could raise
awareness that way.
>> Robert J. Benz: I like
that, Twitter, good idea.
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.:
And if Frederick Douglass were here
today he would probably have 10
million Twitter followers.
[laughter]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Robert J. Benz: Yes, I'm
going to give you the e-mail
of the Ambassador so you
can send them all to.
By the way, I just wanted to
say that I reject the notion
that we're better than
Frederick Douglass, come on.
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.:
Flows through my veins.
[laughter]
>> Robert J. Benz: We
only aspire to be half
as good as Frederick Douglass.
Other ideas?
Any ideas on other service projects?
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Robert J. Benz: Okay,
you are an activist,
I can tell it's in your heart.
By the way, all the folks up here
in front have 4.0 grade averages.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert J. Benz: Just a few
points above what mine was, but.
[laughter] Nettie?
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.:
So you heard Robert say
that we do have envelopes in the
back of the room and if you'd
like to take one and mail in a
donation it is tax deductible
to this project and we would
accept that, of course.
Those of you that are great
with technology and know-how
to text keywords you can text
a keyword FD 2018 to 71777,
so you would open up a new
text message and in the line
where you would type phone
numbers type 71777 and then
in the message part type in FD 2018,
click send and you'll get a link
where you can go and you can make
a donation today and for any amount
if you'd like to and
every little bit helps.
So we thank you very much for that.
>> Robert J. Benz: If
you do it in multiples
of four you know you're
buying one book for a student.
Can I have all of you
students, maybe beginning
with this gentleman,
kind of come up.
I will give you a book as you're
passing by and you can say hello.
And, by the way, we're talking about
hugging, feel free to hug me today.
[laughter] You can hug me, too.
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.:
So these are the first books.
>> Robert J. Benz: Let's
start with this gentleman.
These are the first books.
[ Applause ]
>> Kenneth B. Morris, Jr.: So we
can file through quickly here.
[laughter]
[ Book Distribution ]
>> Robert J. Benz: Feel
free to take pictures,
send them out on Twitter,
put them on Facebook.
We appreciate that.
>> I just wanted to
say hello to Jeremy
and Leslie Alexander, thank you.
Come and greet the great, great,
great grandson of Frederick
Douglass.
[ Book Distribution ]
>> Robert J. Benz: If you are
from another city and you would
like to see Frederick Douglass
Family Initiatives come
to your city help us find a
way to get there with a bunch
of books and we'll be there.
[ Book Distribution ]
>> Kenneth B. Morris,
Jr.: So in the same way
that Frederick Douglass starts to
be critical about his condition
when he starts to get
educated, we want young people
to take Frederick Douglass' words
and to think about the condition
of oppression of many people around
the country, people of color,
the poor and the oppressed, and
how media shapes your consciousness
in who you are and how there are
institutions that can inspire
to hold people down, there's
systemic racism and issues
of inequality and injustice.
Frederick Douglass was about
fighting for human rights for all.
He spoke up, he was one of the
first statesmen of any race to speak
out for women's rights
and women's suffrage.
He spoke out for the
rights of immigrants.
And it's because he
understood what injustice was.
And so as we take this
project forward remember
that this is a project
about human rights
and that we all have this
history in us and we can carry
that forward with this work.
So I ask you to take this and,
Reggie, thank you very much.
Will you stand up, Reggie, please?
We've been working with Reggie for
a couple of years in other schools.
And turn around so people
can see how much you look
like Frederick Douglass.
[laughter]
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.